well that's not just Mexico
it is such a joy it is such a joy to be
here how about all right I love you too
sir
so that meant did the guys only the guys
ever the girl under house band tonight
they've top regional airplay charts in
both Mexico and the United States please
welcome Kelly Brett 50
now as you can tell by the title my
mission here in your beautiful country
is to tape a show made by a Mexican
staff and crew in a Mexican television
studio and starring the Mexican people
and in addition to some very special
guests I'm honored to be joined by my
friend Andres Antonio de los Richter
how are you I'm having a great time yeah
it's fantastic here Mexico is one of the
only countries that a sousaphone player
can still get ladies adventures I've had
over the past week but first I'm going
to attempt to tell you some jokes in
espanol may God have mercy on me please
be kind okay are you ready for this here
we go
when approaches me llamo Colonel Brian
si Oh Oh como me konasana Mexico el
gringo que llora cuando coming
me llamo tiene mucho estar aqui en
mexico el vuelo de los angeles a la
ciudad de mexico solodar de tres horas
Emilia si pero el taxi del aeropuerto a
local Tod oh dear
[Applause]
and molesters por el muro si yo se yo se
todo el Daniel came when a casa el muro
me esposa comes through your room okay
the VA we don't have sex okay today can
a suit that the medic oh se-hoon de unas
NT Metro's cada año see but you creo que
no están crab a wave of años de se no
delay
[Applause]
he was that time Yancey
melih pasado me bein a bit of bastante
tequila tequila me gusta por dos rezones
uno de hace olvidar today todo e no
recuerdo numero monster is your savannas
you de de mexico tambien SL oh god I
Carlos Slim si pero lo que nadie sabe SK
slim empezó como Modelo por supuesto
Carlos Slim es el famoso bein REO
Mexicano El Segundo hombre McCrystal del
mundo Bascom
Andy do you know what the hell I was
talking about I never listen
you